Hello.
Brings the total missing
in West Pine to five,
all within 36 hours.
Shhh!
Who are you?
You must never tell a soul.
Deep in the woods
stands a lone door.
My colony and
all of our practices
exist entirely
to protect the world
from the awful things
beyond that door.
I worry that the wrong person
could learn about this door
and let all those
awful things go free.
Carrie, what's behind the door?
Nightmares.
Your worst nightmares.
Are you like the Terminator?
Have you seen this girl?
I've never seen her.
Tasha, this particular girl
is a cold stone killer.
You sure she's not around
the corner in your kitchen,
or in your bedroom?
I'm here to help you.
Ready to hunt a monster?
This is so metal.
I'm going to end this thing.
- Why are you walking like that?
- It's my power pose,
I do it before recitals
when I’m nervous.
Oh, hell’s greatest weakness:
empowered dancers.
I feel so safe.